think there's there's places for all
things in all music and
uh everybody's kind of influenced by
other things and i think it's important
to always bring those influences
in when you can and i'm fortunate enough
to bring my actual influences
and to make a record with me and you
know who gets to do that
that's that's incredible and so i'm
gonna do that you know i've always done
that you know robert turner's played on
records of mine
uh mickey rafael's played on records of
mine you know it's
i to get these musicians who have formed
all these records that i've listened to
over
the years that kind of always are
informing
how i think musically and then to get to
play with them and make new music with
them well that's
that's an awesome thing it's always very
special and i missed her very much
tonight but i was so happy that
uh miranda agreed to fill in kind of
last minute uh i think my sister-in-law
is in labor right now she may be on her
way to the hospital i'm not sure
so um that my wife was kind of on baby
watch so
and for once not her own baby but uh
it's it's been a
an interesting night tonight so lots to
celebrate
and um you know the awards are just part
of it
there's nothing i'm looking forward to
more
than seeing the faces of people out in
the crowd and hearing them sing back to
me
and hopefully hearing some of these new
songs sung back back to us because
that's when music really gets live to me
is when you know i can write a song and
i can record a song and i can sing it
in a room by myself but it doesn't mean
a whole lot until it goes
out to somebody out in an audience or
somebody
sitting at home listening or somebody
listening in their car that's when it
gets meaning and so
for me that's the thing i'm most looking
forward to is to get back out into the
world
and see people and have played music
with them and enjoy that experience that
we have together
in a room playing live music
you